- Here he comes, here he comes.
- San Diego, baby!
- You remember my friend, Steven?
- What's up?
- Yeah dude, we're gonna
record all these memories
and watch them everyday. Yeah!
("Breaking All the Rules" by Warner)
[Zack] Yo, we got the beach,
Sea World, California burritos
- [Justin] The best weekend.
- [Zack] With my best friend.
Man, Airbnb really came through.
- It's gonna be a dope weekend.
Woah.
- This place is perfect.
- It's huge.
- Home sweet home, baby.
Man, check this out.
- [Zack] Yo, what we got?
- [Justin] 30 stocked.
- [Zack] Yo, to the best weekend.
- I can't get over how nice this place is.
- I know right, like what?
(ping pong ball taps on ground)
(spooky noise)
Hey check this out. The TV's
just playing Mario cart.
- So?
- It's not connected to
a console, I checked.
- I mean, it's probably
Bluetooth or whatever, you know?
- This is weird, right?
(spooky static noise)
Yo Steve, are you hearing that?
(men chanting)
What? Hello?
I'm telling you, there's some weird stuff
that's going on right now.
- [Justin] Zack, did you set this up?
- No, was this you Steve?
- [Steven] No.
- [Justin] Who set this up?
Whatever man, let's just
have a great San Diego.
Yo Steven, get over here,
Zack and I are on fire.
(man laughs) Are you kidding me?
We're hitting a world record.
- You're getting
everything on this, right?
- [Creepy Voiceover] No bounces.
- That just exploded, what was that?
- Did you hear that?
It says this house used
to be a frat house.
- [Steven] What happened?
- It got shut down for partying too hard.
- Get a late night snack. Oh, what's this?
Alright Zack, good one. You got me.
- What are you doing?
- (croaking) Your turn.
- I'm good.
- [Zack] Yo, you excited
to hike La Jolla tomorrow?
- Sounds like a sausage fest, dude.
- [Zack] What?
- I'm not going unless there are chicks.
- I'm telling you,
Justin's been acting weird.
I'm gonna set up this camera,
see if he does anything weird tonight.
(metal scratch tune)
Yo, get the camera.
Yo, what is that? What is that?
Hey, what were you doing last night?
- I don't know what
you're talking about, bro.
- No, you do, I saw you on camera.
- You filming me, pledge?
Zackie! You taking a monster deuce, bro?
- I have no other choice.
- Take me to him.
Listen, Justin's my best friend.
- Okay, well he's my best friend.
- He's my best friend, but before that,
I was a bro. (male choir singing)
He was the one that helped
me stop being a bro.
Now it's time to help him.
(sudden spooky music)
Hey, what's up bro? I got the new GTA 5
and some Family Guy DVR'd if
you just wanna kick it, fam.
You need to break the bro code.
If we break the bro code,
the demons will come out.
- Give me a music festival.
- Coachella, I don't know.
- You've got no money to
go to Coachella this year.
(grunting noise)
You're not crushing it, bro.
(growling noise)
- It's not working!
- DDM an actor of the bro
(Justin screaming and laughing)
You need to chill.
(Justin yells demonically)
He's too powerful.
I don't know if you know,
but I studied in Europe.
And the word they used
for bro is fraterna,
it's their number one bro.
You're his number one bro
now. Only you can save him.
- That's not my bro in there.
- [Guy in Hat] A bro
never leaves a bro behind.
(static noises)
(door squeaks)
(clapping)
(Zack yells)
("Breaking All the Rules" by Warner)
(light piano)
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh, yeah.
(snare drum)
You don't know the half of it.
(light piano)